[Applaus]
ja guten Morgen meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren herzlich willkommen
auch hier oben von der Bühne wir freuen
uns dass Sie so zahlreiche Schienen sind
und besonders begrüßen darf ich Frau
Professor Dr Veronika Grimm von der
Universität Erlangen Nürnberg sie haben
eine Professur für Volkswirtschaftslehre
vor Grimm und sind unter anderem meine
Spezialisten für Energiethemen das ist
für uns heute ganz wichtig sie gehören
seit 2020 dem
Sachverständigenrat zu Begutachtung der
gesamtwirtschaftlichen Entwicklung an
und sie haben auch sonst weitere
Tätigkeit sie waren letztes Jahr
Leiterin dieser Kommission die sich mit
Gaspreisen befasst hat
wer könnte kompetenter sein mit uns über
ein Härtetest für die deutsche
Wirtschaft zu sprechen einer der
größeren Härtetest wird sein dass wir 45
Minuten haben und die deutsche
Wirtschaft zu behandeln und wir wollen
das nicht nur Zwiegespräch machen
sondern wenn Sie gerne auch einbinden
wir werden dann Mikrofone haben und ich
darf jetzt schon sagen wenn Sie sich
beteiligen möchten bitte stellen sich
kurz vor und bitte fragen Sie
idealerweise auch nicht zu lang damit
möglichst viele zu Wort kommen können ja
dann wollen wir loslegen Frau grimmowski
eine hat ja angesprochen vom halben Jahr
haben wir über Versorgungssicherheit
gesprochen das war eigentlich letztes
Jahr dann ein neues Thema für viele es
ist immer noch eins wie beurteilen sie
denn die Versorgungssicherheit Punkte
Energie ja ich glaube erstmal haben wir
Glück gehabt und vor allen Dingen haben
auch Glück gehabt dass wir jetzt wieder
hier tatsächlich mit Publikum sitzen ich
war vor zwei Jahren glaube ich bei den
Kongress eingeladen und da war das ohne
Publikum ich glaube der Krise haben wir
überwunden
herzlichen Dank auch für die Einladung
mit Blick auf die Energieversorgung sind
wir glaube ich jetzt wirklich gut
weggekommen in diesem Winter wir haben
einerseits Lücke gehabt der Winter war
warm und man muss auch sehen in China
war Lockdown und deswegen war die
Gasnachfrage aus dem asiatischen Raum
relativ niedrig das zusammen mit den
politischen Maßnahmen die ergriffen
wurden LG Beschaffung Gas Spahn ist ja
auch ganz gut gelungen hat uns
eigentlich sehr gut über diesen Winter
gebracht und hat auch ein bisschen den
Druck rausgenommen wir haben jetzt schon
Sachverständigenrat auch unsere Prognose
revidiert wir hatten im Herbst einen
leichten Rückgang der
Wirtschaftsleistung vorher gesagt und
jetzt gehen wir von
0,2% Wachstum das aus insofern sieht es
besser aus allerdings ist es so dass mit
Blick auf den nächsten Winter eigentlich
ähnliche Probleme vor der Tür stehen die
Gasspeicher sind nämlich zwischendurch
nicht größer geworden die Gasspeicher
reichen immer noch wenn es wirklich sehr
kalt wird ungefähr für zwei Monate das
heißt wir müssen die wieder auffüllen
und in China ist die Wirtschaft wieder
angesprungen der Lockdown ist ja beendet
es gab dann in China eine coronawelle
die noch dazu geführt hat dass weniger
produziert wurde aber jetzt geht es
wieder los und wenn aus Ostasien die
Nachfrage wieder kommt dann dürfte dann
könnten natürlich auch noch mal die
Preise steigen insofern Entwarnung würde
ich jetzt nicht gehen es ist eher so
dass in der sehr sehr kurzen Frist durch
die niedrigen Energiepreise jetzt und
auch durch die Preis bremsen die gehen
ja ein bisschen Sicherheit für die
Wirtschaft
dass dadurch eigentlich die Entwicklung
besser als erwartet ist aber die Risiken
sind schon noch da und man darf glaube
ich nicht zu sehr entwarnen und muss
einfach immer wieder klar machen für die
nächsten Winter müssen wir wieder
Vorsorge treffen und wir würden sie das
Thema versorgensicherheit längerfristig
sehen wir sind in einer Energiewende wir
wollen aus fossilen Energien heraus wir
brauchen dann aber auch erneuerbare
gleichzeitig würden Strombedarf zunehmen
etwa die Elektrifizierung des
Autoverkehrs aber auch durch anderes
sind wir da längerfristig gut
aufgestellt also haben wir so etwas wie
eine Energiepolitik ja wir müssen uns
einfach längerfristig gut aufstellen es
ist nämlich richtig wir sind ja aus
verschiedenen Technologien ausgestiegen
Kernkraft Kohle wir haben natürlich
nicht genug Gaskraftwerke um jetzt
unmittelbar die Kohlekraftwerke zu
ersetzen das heißt wir verstrumen durch
den Kern
energieausstieg jetzt aktuell sehr viel
Kohle und das muss natürlich aufhören
weil wir unsere Emissionen dadurch in
die Höhe treiben
wir stehen jetzt nicht besonders gut da
und machen natürlich auch international
keinen besonders guten Eindruck das
heißt wir müssen schauen dass wir
zubauen und das muss jetzt auch
passieren wir brauchen eigentlich eine
Angebotspolitik bei der
Energieversorgung Strom
Erzeugung zu bauen also einerseits
erneuerbare Energien das ist ja sehr
breit in der Diskussion aber eben auch
Gaskraftwerke wir brauchen zwischen 20
und 30 Gigawatt Gaskraftwerk
Kapazitäten um tatsächlich aus der Kohle
aussteigen zu können idealerweise möchte
man ja bis 2030 aus der kohleausstiegen
dann braucht man tatsächlich diese
gaskapazitäten das sind jetzt kommt
drauf an kommt drauf an wie viel
Kapazität ein Kraftwerk hat das könnten
so 20 bis 30 kleinere Kraftwerke sein
die muss man erstmal bauen da müsste man
jetzt langsam mal anfangen und
erneuerbaren Energien müssen auch viel
schneller ausbauen viermal so schnell
ist die Ansage wie historisch ist eine
riesige Herausforderung die Anlagen
müssen ja geplant genehmigt werden und
dann auch noch gebaut werden das in
Betrieb gehen können die Netze müssen
zugebaut werden also wir haben so
einiges vor der Brust und müssen das
schaffen und da braucht man schon diese
neue Deutschland Geschwindigkeit die
immer diskutiert wird ja wir sind da
glaube ich ganz gut darin feste
ausstiegspunkte zu nennen um aus
bestimmten Energien heraus dazu kommen
aber wir sind vielleicht nicht so
schnell dann eben für für Alternativen
zu sorgen in diesem Zusammenhang halten
Sie es für glücklich dass wir aus der
Kernenergie aussteigen ja ich habe mich
dazu ja schon vielfach geäußert habe
auch viel eingesteckt dafür also ich
hätte es gut gefunden wenn wir noch drei
vier Jahre dranhängen einfach deshalb
weil wir durch den Ausstieg aus der
Kernenergie jetzt natürlich die
Strompreise senken
also erhöhen wir würden sie denken wenn
wir aussteigen würden wir erhöhen die
Emissionen weil natürlich die
Kernkraftwerke einige Kohlekraftwerke
aus dem Kraftwerk rausdrängen könnten
aus der merit order so dass die ihm
seltener produzieren müssen und wir
müssen natürlich mehr Gas verstromen
wenn wir die Kernenergie nicht zur
Verfügung haben also das diese drei
Argumente sollte man eigentlich ernst
nehmen in dieser Krisensituation und
wenn man sich das anguckt wir haben auch
eine Studie dazu gerechnet die
Rahmenbedingungen unter denen wir die
Szenarien gerechnet haben sind jetzt ein
bisschen anderer aber ich glaube die
Ergebnisse sind trotzdem noch relativ
gut interpretierbar es ist so dass man
in drei vier Jahren die Kernkraftwerke
tatsächlich wenn man unsere Ausbauziele
bei den Erneuerbaren erreicht nicht mehr
so dringend brauchen würde weil dann
würden die Kernkraftwerke nämlich nicht
Kohlekraftwerke aus der Training sondern
im Wesentlichen erneuerbare Energien
verdrängen
von der Erzeugungsleistung her und dann
könnte man sagen naja dann können wir
umsteigen auf diesen Mix aus
wasserstoffbetriebenen Gaskraftwerken
die wir uns vorstellen und den
erneuerbaren Energien aber jetzt in den
nächsten drei Jahren ist die Situation
noch angespannt sie würden aber
[Applaus]
sie würden aber sagen die wenn wir die
Pläne die es gibt in der Lage wären
rasch umzusetzen das ist ja sein großes
wenn
dann würden wir uns auf einem Weg
befinden der uns in eine gute Zukunft
führt ja aber es wird auch dauern also
ich glaube man darf sich nicht vormachen
dass die Energiepreise jetzt
sehr sehr schnell auf einen Niveau
runtergehen dass unter dem historischen
Niveau liegt also jetzt erstmal werden
wir dadurch dass die fossilen Energien
teuer bleiben teurer bleiben als sie das
historisch waren weil wir müssen ja von
dem russischen Gas umsteigen auf das
teurere Eltern LG dadurch wird die
Energieversorgung erstmal teurer sein
und dann wenn wir jetzt massiv ausbauen
erneuerbare dann bedeutet das natürlich
umso besser wir darin sind dass du
stärker geben die Preise wieder nach
aber das wird natürlich dauern das geht
nicht von heute auf morgen und ich
glaube wir müssen uns in Deutschland
schon darauf einstellen dass wir einfach
in einem anderen Umfeld sind und zwar
einerseit aufgrund dieser höheren
Energiepreise generell und dann
natürlich auch aufgrund der Tatsache
dass wir generell eine sehr disruptive
Veränderung in unserem gesamten
Energiesystem haben wir wollen ja
elektrifizieren also wir werden ja auch
viel mehr Energie brauchen ist ja nicht
so dass wir Energie zu bauen und damit
die bestehende Stromversorgung abdecken
müssen sondern wir bauen Energie zu und
müssen so schnell sein dass wir diesen
massiv steigenden Strombedarf abdecken
also von 580 Karat Stunden pro Jahr
heute auf
antizipiert laut bmwk ich glaube das ist
auch realistisch 750 terrarat Stunden im
Jahr 2030 und ungefähr eine Verdoppelung
des Strombedarfs durch die
Elektrifizierung in der langfrist und
das muss man erstmal schaffen das ist
schon eine Herausforderung was bedeutet
dies denn für die deutsche Wirtschaft
und speziell für die deutsche Industrie
es gibt ja durchaus ein iPhone Menschen
die Angst haben vor einer der
Industrialisierung Deutschlands sind
diese Sorgen
gerechtfertigt nur ganz kurz daran als
wir in den 70er Jahren eine den
Ölpreisschock hatten da gab es auch
schon der Button über das Ende der
deutschen Industrie es ist nicht
gekommen aber
wie soll man wie kann man sich dieses
Mal die Zukunft vorstellen ja glaube ich
auch nicht also ich glaube nicht dass
wir die industrialisieren aber es wird
sich viel tun und umso besser wir diese
Prozesse begleiten und umso weniger
Bestandshaltung wir betreiben umso
stärker wir wirklich zukunftsgerichtet
agieren desto besser wird auch ausgehen
vielleicht mal
ein Beispiel warum Bestandshaltung
einfach auch sehr problematisch sein
kann in der energieintensiven Industrie
Stahlindustrie Chemieindustrie aber auch
Glas Papier das sind ja alles Industrien
die man nicht komplett elektrifizieren
kann da werden wir Wasserstoff und
darauf basierende erneuerbare
Energieträger brauchen und erneuerbaren
Wasserstoff den erzeugt man indem man
mittels einer elektrolyseanlage Wasser
in seine Bestandteile Sauerstoff und
Wasserstoff spaltet und überhaupt
input-faktor ist Strom billiger Strom
billiger Strom das wird aber etwas sein
was wir in Europa nicht so schnell zur
Verfügung haben werden einfach weil wir
im Rahmen der Transformation zur
Klimaneutralität jetzt unsere
Stromversorgung erstmal ausbauen müssen
also wir kämpfen ja darum genug
erneuerbaren Strom auszubauen und haben
ganz viele andere Abnehmer außer den
elektrolyseuren die auch noch den
erneuerbaren Strom verbrauchen wollen
Batterie elektrische Fahrzeuge
Wärmepumpen Betriebe die elektrifizieren
das heißt wir werden diesen Wasserstoff
aus Regionen weltweit importieren müssen
das wird gerade auch schon angedacht es
gibt viele Partnerschaften Gespräche mit
Regionen weltweit die sehr sehr günstige
Bedingungen für die Erzeugung von
erneuerbaren Energien haben also wo
niedrige Gestehungskosten möglich sind
und dort wird man auf Dauer auch den
Wasserstoff erzeugen und nach Europa
transportieren die Prognosen sagen so
ungefähr 80% werden importieren 20%
werden wir bei uns herstellen wenn wir
aber den Wasserstoff importieren wollen
dann ist es eigentlich so dass man den
nicht so gut transportieren kann das
sind sehr leichtes flüchtiges Gas für
den Schiffstransport überhaupt nicht
geeignet das heißt wir müssen es in
idealerweise verflüssigen verflüssigen
laut aktuellen Stand der Technologie ist
Ammoniak und Methanol sehr günstig und
Ammoniak ist ein Produkt das wir heute
mittels Fossil im Gas in Deutschland
herstellen im Rahmen der chemischen
Industrie dann wird aus Ammoniak zum
Beispiel Düngemittel hergestellt sehr
wahrscheinlich ist dass wir einen großen
Teil dieses Ammoniaks
importieren werden zukünftig und dann
sozusagen den Rest der
Wertschöpfungskette idealerweise in
Deutschland abwickeln aber man sieht das
schon da wird Wertschöpfung verloren
gehen und wenn wir uns dagegen werden
wollen wir haben letztens eine Studie
gemacht wo wir diese
Wertschöpfungsketten mal berechnet haben
das würde es eigentlich bringen für ein
Kostenvorteil wenn wir das Importieren
aus exzellenten Regionen versus wenn wir
es mit grünem Wasserstoff hierherstellen
und dann sieht man dass die kosten
ungefähr um 25% in den Berechnungen
überlegen würden wenn man es im
portoxidiert das ist etwas wo man nicht
gegen ansubventionieren kann und ich
glaube diese Transformationen die muss
man sehr gezielt begleiten in der
Stahlindustrie haben wir ähnliche
Zusammenhänge da fragt sich importieren
wir den Wasserstoff oder importieren wer
Rohstahl in der Stahlindustrie ist der
Kostenvorteil der imports Substitution
aber nicht so groß und da ist es gut wie
es jetzt auch in der Stahlindustrie
passiert dass man die gesamte
Wertschöpfungskette einmal bei uns
ansiedelt dass man die
Technologiekompetenz hat dass man das
Bauen kann aber ob wir das alles in
Deutschland einfach replizieren
klimaneutral das ist sehr unklar
wahrscheinlich werden wir da entlang
dieser Wertschöpfungsketten irgendwo
auch Import substituieren um die Kosten
zu senken möglichst an der Stelle wie
zum Beispiel Ammoniak wo es commodity
die Märkte gibt wo der entsprechende
Energieträger oder die Substanz die wir
importieren weltweit auf liquidenmärkten
gehandelt wird so dass wir eben nicht in
Abhängigkeiten wieder reinlaufen wenn
wir das nicht tun wenn wir das laufen
lassen und sagen und es ist egal guck
mal was passiert dann kann es eben sein
dass wir schnell wieder von Staaten
abhängig werden die uns auch nicht so
freundlich gesonnen sind und das muss
man politisch eng begleiten ich glaube
es nützt nichts dagegen komplett
anzusubventionieren
dispotenzial sollten wir uns aufrecht
erhalten für zukunftsindustrie wo wir
echt komparative Vorteile haben die
Technologiekompetenz die Fachkräfte und
so weiter und bei gewissen Prozessen
muss man wirklich hinnehmen dass es
abwandert und ich glaube das muss man
sehr sehr eng politisch begleiten weil
das sind natürlich das ist natürlich ein
Strukturwandel der auch viele
Potenzial für gesellschaftliche Unruhe
hat die Menschen werden natürlich
unruhig das bedeutet Arbeitsplätze das
bedeutet Strukturwandel in den Regionen
man muss den Menschen auch sehr sehr
klar sagen was sind denn die Chancen wie
gestalten sich die Übergangsprozess auf
welchen Zeitachsen also das sind schon
herausfordernde Zeiten die da auf uns
zukommen ja sie haben einen Punkt
angesprochen der glaube ich ganz wichtig
ist man kann ja
technische Möglichkeiten haben man die
auch eine wirtschaftliche Logik besitzen
aber man muss tatsächlich wenn es sich
um eine ganz tiefgreifende
Transformation handelt im Menschen
mitnehmen und da glaube ich auch das
Verständnis dafür wecken dass eben im
wirtschaftliche und nachhaltige
Gesichtspunkte auch zusammenpassen und
nicht im Widerspruch stehen und
meines Erachtens könnte die Politik die
sich drückt mal ganz vorsichtig aus
besser kommunizieren
denn mein Eindruck ist dass bei vielen
Menschen
grundsätzliches Verständnis für das
Thema Klima wächst aber sie ganz so
Recht fragen was bedeutet das denn für
mich für mein Leben für mein Wohlstand
und wenn man die Diskussion jetzt nimmt
um um die Heizung etwa da wird ja jeder
Mensch unmittelbar betroffen ja und mein
Eindruck ist dass man das besser
kommunizieren müsste
ja ich glaube man muss die Menschen
mitnehmen ich glaube man muss ihnen auch
auch von Seiten der Politik glaube ich
deutlich reineren Wein einschenken es
wird sich sehr sehr viel ändern wir
müssen mit diesen disruptionen umgehen
und wir werden auch gegeben die vielen
Herausforderungen die da sind wir sehen
das ja mit den Krisen Corona jetzt die
Energiekrise dann wackeln wackelt im
Finanzsektor so ein bisschen das ist
alles sehr schwer interpretierbar da
haben wir die geopolitischen Spannung
und das werden schon herausfordernde
Zeiten auch die Tatsache dass die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit wieder viel
wichtiger wird also man muss den
Menschen schon klar machen es sind jetzt
ganz andere Zeiten die da auf uns
zukommen und ich glaube die zweite Lehre
die wir jetzt aus diesen letzten Jahren
ziehen müssen ist dass wir auch
aufpassen müssen wenn ich in unseren
bubbles bleiben und dadurch die
Bedürfnisse der Menschen die eben auch
alle betroffen sind übersehen weil
vieles ist natürlich in der politischen
debabbel oder in der Wissenschaft oder
in der Wirtschaft diskutiert und geklärt
aber noch bei den Menschen vielleicht so
gar nicht angekommen und da muss man
glaube ich sehr dafür sorgen dass die
Menschen mitgenommen werden und das auch
Optionen eröffnet werden also Optionen
eröffnet werden sich anzupassen bevor
man aus Dingen aussteigt dass hat das
heizungsthema ja auch gezeigt also wenn
ich jetzt sagen will es sollen kann eine
Gas und Ölheizung mehr eingebaut werden
dann muss ich eigentlich auch
gleichzeitig sagen was für Optionen
eröffne ich denn um den Einstieg in
klimafreundlicherhaltungstechnologien
die dann auch für die verschiedenen
Anwendungsfälle verfügbar sind um den
Einstieg vorzunehmen
[Applaus]
an der marktwirtschaftlich geprägten
Wirtschaftsredaktion wird glaube ich bei
diesem Thema ohnehin viel zu wenig über
über Alternativen gesprochen über
technologieoffenheit über man das wird
zu häufig der Eindruck erweckt es gäbe
einen Weg den man gehen muss und im
Zweifel muss man ihn anordnen
anstatt sich die Frage zu stellen ob
nicht gerade auch in offenen
Gesellschaften eben
der Diskurs auch der Austausch von von
Ideen und von die Diskussion von
Optionen ein weiterführen kann und da
scheint es tatsächlich diese Bubble zu
geben eine eine zum Teil Technologie
getriebene Babbel und dann eine eher
Ökonomie getriebene Bubble sie sind da
ja das kann man ja sagen auf auf Twitter
auch
aktiv geworden hängt es denn dass da der
Austausch nicht so richtig stattfindet
weil ich glaube ihm im Sinne der Zukunft
unseres Landes nicht nur der Wirtschaft
wäre ganz sinnvoll ja also einen Aspekt
ist dass wir glaube ich in den
Wirtschaftswissenschaften gerade wenn
man merkt orientierte kon attraktiv
findet Schwierigkeiten hat diese Dinge
tatsächlich zu kommunizieren das sind ja
auch Dinge die entweder unangenehm sind
Emissionshandel die Preise müssen
steigen ja ist nicht jeder dabei in dem
Moment wo es dann ans Eingemachte geht
und man das tatsächlich umsetzen soll
zuckt die Politik natürlich davor auch
zurück obwohl es ein ziemlich
effizientes Mittel wäre
Wandel auszulösen weil wenn ich weiß es
wird einfach wahnsinnig teuer wenn wir
alle Fossil weitermachen dann überlege
ich mir was dann kommt ja diese
Innovationskraft zum Tragen und die
Menschen und die Unternehmen sind dabei
Lösungen zu entwickeln die dann
typischerweise auch sehr gut
funktionieren und die typischerweise
auch sehr stark dieser Heterogenität der
verschiedenen Anwendung gerecht werden
aber es ist sehr sehr schwer zu
vermitteln dominant ist diese technische
Diskussion dass man in Modellen
ausrechnet was brauchen wir eigentlich
ne wie viel Wärmepumpen wie viel
Fernwärme und so weiter und oftmals ist
es auch so dass die ähm
Perspektive dann auch ist eine
Wärmepumpe kostet in meinem Haus wohnen
so viel oder in einer idealen Anwendung
und das kann ich doch dann einfach 60
Millionen Mal oder 40 Millionen Mal
machen das ist natürlich ein Illusion
weil in Systemen gibt es dann immer noch
Komplexität die dann nicht mitgedacht
wird wenn man 20 Millionen Wärmepumpen
hat dann braucht man natürlich auch den
Ausbau der Stromerzeugung dann braucht
man natürlich auch den Ausbau der
Stromnetze und zwar der
der
Verteilnetze und der Übertragungsnetze
und dann ist man natürlich ganz schnell
bei mehr als dem Aufwand sowohl zeitlich
als auch finanziell den es braucht um
eine einzelne werbepumpe zu installieren
das muss man mitdenken das schwierig zu
diskutieren diese Komplexität macht es
schwer zu vermitteln und diese
Komplexität führt auch dazu dass man
eigentlich viele verschiedene Szenarien
rechnen und plausibilisieren kann die
bestimmten Akteuren nehmen sich dann das
was Ihnen gut passt und argumentieren
also die Diskussion ist nicht so einfach
aber man muss sie führen und ähm ich
glaube das auch ein großer Fehler jetzt
in der aktuellen klimapolitischen
Diskussion war nicht den Emissionshandel
im Hintergrund zu etablieren da müsste
man eigentlich eine gesellschaftliche
Allianz haben das tut auch weh
aber wenn wir es schaffen würden den
Emissionshandel der ja im
Bundesimmissionsschutzgesetz schon
angelegt ist den wir ohnehin schon
beschlossen haben da Klarheit zu
schaffen den zu schärfen zu sagen dass
und das ist das Kontingent bis 2030 und
dann später bis 2045 und das setzen wir
durch das würde es natürlich allen
zukünftigen Regierung also der jetzigen
und auch einen zukünftigen viel leichter
machen Politik zu machen weil die
Erreichung der Klimaziele wäre dann
durch den Emissionshandel sichergestellt
und dann muss man natürlich Kommentare
Maßnahmen etablieren die ist den
Menschen leicht machen damit umzugehen
man muss überlegen dass man den
Emissionshandel einführt und auch sozial
entlastet zum Beispiel die Einnahmen
rückverteilt pro Kopf so dass diejenigen
die nicht viele Missionen haben
relativ zu ihren Belastungen
zurückkriegen das sind typischerweise
die armenhaushalte also man kann da viel
machen aber man muss sich eben auch dazu
durchringen dazu bräuchte es
wahrscheinlich eine breitere politische
Kooperation ich habe nicht verstanden
warum man es im Koalitionsausschuss
nicht versucht hat also die FDP einige
FDP-Politiker hatten ja so ein Vorschlag
gemacht man hätte da der FDP durchaus
auch mal die Pistole auf die Brust
setzen können und sagen können wir
nehmen euch jetzt beim Wort das machen
wir jetzt gemeinsam und dann weichen wir
die Sektor viele im Klimaschutzgesetz
auf ich glaube das wäre eine gute Sache
gewesen
wenn wir diesen Punkt vielleicht ganz
kurz zusammenfassen wollten könnte man
sagen die deutsche Wirtschaft steht vor
einem Härtetest und ähm es wird auch ein
Wandel geben aber es wäre vielleicht
auch ganz sinnvoll die mit dem Wandel
verbundenen Chancen zu sehen auch gerade
für innovative Unternehmen für für gut
ausgebildete
arbeitskräftig wird zu einem anderen
Härtetest gern kommen der betrifft uns
vor allen Dingen als Verbraucher und als
Sparer der hatte Test ist die Inflation
jetzt gehen im Augenblick hier raten ja
leicht zurück aber also ein wenig nicht
so schnell
wie schätzen sie da die Perspektiven ein
müssen wir mit Inflation noch lange
leben sollte man anders gegen sie
vorgehen ja es wird nicht so schnell
gehen dass sie zurückgeht also für
dieses Jahr sind wir beim in unserer in
unserem Konjunktur Update noch bei 6,6
Prozent dann geht es im nächsten Jahr
zurück auf um die drei aber da sind wir
immer noch nicht beim langfristigen
jetzt bei mittelfristigen Inflationsziel
der EZB von 2%, das heißt so richtig
durch sind wir noch nicht die Aufgabe
ist herausfordernd weil natürlich die
Frage ist wie konsequent müssen sich die
Zentralbanken der Inflation
entgegenstämmen was muss auch der Status
ja ganz viel Diskussion ne ähm müssen
wir da komplementär
seitens des Startens Staates Maßnahmen
ergreifen die gaspreisbremse ein
Beispiel und das ist natürlich auch der
Grund warum es jetzt gerade zurückgeht
ja also die Senkung der der Strom und
Gaspreise durch die gaspreisbremse ich
hätte diesen Effekt ohnehin erzielt
jetzt sind die Preise ohnehin
zurückgegangen und das diese beiden
Dinge zusammen führen dazu dass wir
jetzt gerade einen Rückgang der
Inflation beobachten aber der Druck ist
durchaus noch da und die Situation ist
eigentlich noch herausfordernder
geworden durch die Unruhe an den
Finanzmärkten und jetzt ist eben die
Frage gerade bei der letzten
Entscheidung der EZB war natürlich die
Frage soll man jetzt aus Vorsicht dass
diese die Banken mit den
Zinsänderungsrisiken nicht zu stark zu
belasten diesen Schritt nicht machen das
wäre keine gute Entscheidung gewesen aus
verschiedenen Gründen unter anderem
erstens ist die Inflation tatsächlich
noch nicht bekämpft wir haben diesen
Inflationsdruck noch die Energiepreise
werden in den güterpreisen noch
weitergegeben die Kerninflationsrate
steigt ja gerade noch also jetzt
aufzuhören wäre sehr heikel dann kommt
die Inflation unter Umständen zurück
oder bleibt eben persistent das erhöht
die Inflationserwartungen und dann wird
es noch schwerer
ähm der Inflation Herr zu werden ja also
insofern da sind wir noch nicht durch es
ist angezeigt die Zinskurve weiter hoch
zu gehen durch die Zentralbanken und zum
zweiten ist natürlich so gar nicht so
klar ob man jetzt dieser diese Unruhe an
den Finanzmärkten tatsächlich
eingedämmt hätte weil wenn der Schritt
nicht erfolgt wäre hätte ja auch Zweifel
daran entstehen können ob nicht die EZB
irgendwelche Informationen hat die wir
als Normalbürger nicht haben also ob man
dadurch dann die Wahrscheinlichkeit z.B
von denk drans reduziert hätte das gar
nicht so klar also ich glaube es richtig
dass man Schritt gemacht hat es wird
herausfordernd sein weiterzugehen weil
natürlich diese finanzielle Dominanz
also diese Angst das im Finanzsystem was
passiert und man deswegen zu vorsichtig
ist das spielt jetzt eine Rolle in den
Überlegungen also wird noch mehr eine
Gradwanderung als es das vorher war aber
ich glaube es ist sehr sehr wichtig den
Weg weiterzugehen und tatsächlich die
Priorität darauf zu setzen die Inflation
tatsächlich
wirksam zu bekämpfen ja Anfang Mai ist
der nächste Sitzung ist Zentralbank
gerade zu werden sehen wir haben noch
gut 7 Minuten meine selten Damen und
Herren
sie sind dann wir haben hier eine Frage
wir haben aber Mikros ich sehe hier
ich habe da sie gesehen und und sie
gesehen hier drüben noch nicht mein Name
ist Fritz Müller ich bin von Beruf
Ingenieur und war Zeit meines
lebensunternehmer
sowohl bei ihrem Gespräch jetzt als auch
allgemein der Öffentlichkeit zum Thema
Energie
vermisse ich eine Option und meine Frage
ist diese Option überhaupt noch ein
Thema und das Thema wäre Kernfusion
für mich wäre das der Königsweg und ich
denke alle wirtschaftliche Kraft sollte
auf dies schnelle Entwicklung
konzentriert werden danke
ja ist ein Thema es gibt sogar in
Deutschland Aktivitäten allerdings wird
uns das nicht die Lösung bringen für die
unmittelbaren Herausforderungen also ich
glaube man sollte auf diese Themen
fokussieren aber gleichzeitig muss man
glaube ich ehrlich sein dass wir dass
das jetzt nicht in diesem Jahrzehnt
unsere Probleme lösen wird
insofern glaube ich dass dieses Thema
technologieoffenheit was ich ganz
gefährlich finde ist immer wenn man sagt
wir haben jetzt ausgerechnet wir unsere
Welt aussehen wird 2045 und jetzt bauen
wir die ja das ist natürlich ein
Illusion weil es kommt immer wieder
Neues es werden neue Technologien
Chancen eröffnen und deswegen
dran bleiben aber nicht glauben dass das
die Lösung für die Probleme ist die wir
bis 2030 zu lösen haben wir haben den
ja genau sieht das sehr gut und dann
dann habe ich mein Name ist Schleicher
ich war jetzt erst in Brüssel und habe
die Frau von der Leyen gehört und die
erzählt natürlich die große Story also
narrativ dass jetzt diese green Deal des
riesige Wachstumsprogramm für Europa ist
und auch unser Bundeskanzler Scholz
erzählt dass sie ist da sozusagen das
Wachstum jetzt bald durch die Decke
gehen wird aufgrund dieser
Transformation großen grünen
Transformation auf der anderen Seite
habe ich vor kurzem den Präsidenten des
ifo-Instituts gehört deshalb diese Story
stimmt nicht weil nämlich ein Großteil
unseres vorhandenen Kapitalstocks sie
gern Kraftwerke ersetzt werden muss das
heißt der Kapital Stock wird erst einmal
entwertet und muss wieder ersetzt werden
wir stehen Sie dazu ist das jetzt das
Brot der große Wachstumstreiber oder ist
die grüne Transformation erst einmal
kein großer Wachstumstreiber
ja spannende Frage ich würde eigentlich
ich würde eigentlich denken dass wir
unser narrativ da anpassen müssen die
Frage ist glaube ich nicht wir können
die gar nicht so isoliert stellen wie
realisieren wir hier bei uns in
Deutschland oder sogar in Europa
ausreichend Wachstum sondern wir müssen
eigentlich diese geopolitische Lage uns
angucken und uns überlegen wie stellen
wir uns eigentlich in dieser neuen Welt
vernünftig auf und dazu gehört ganz
stark die Umstellung unserer
Energieversorgung die Transformation in
ein klimaneutrales Energiesystem weil
wir werden dabei ganz viele
Handelsbeziehungen aufbauen müssen und
auch ganz vielen Ländern weltweit
Chancen eröffnen müssen also ein ganz
großer Treiber von Beschleunigung der
klimafreundlichen Energieversorgung wird
dadurch geschehen dass wir in großen
Volumina Energie importieren werden
grüne Energie importieren werden
wasserstoffen darauf basierende grüne
Energieträger um ein Beispiel zu machen
wenn wir zehn Terawattstunden also die
Prognosen für 2030 für die Bedarfe an
grünem Wasserstoff sind 350 bis 90
Terawattstunden
jährlich wenn wir zehn Terawattstunden
importieren wollen dann wären das wäre
das ein Investment von 10 Milliarden zum
Beispiel in Australien oder Namibia
Innenanlagen und Opera und und
Betriebskosten von 500 Millionen dann
würden wir so zwei zweieinhalb Schiffe
immer hin und her fahren haben wie LNG
eigentlich und äh Energie importieren
das bräuchten wir nicht nur einmal
sondern eben fünf sechs sieben Mal ähm
das heißt da wird ganz viel passieren
und da wird natürlich auch Wachstum
passieren und da muss man eben auch
sehen dass man dann die Beziehungen zu
den exportieren so gestaltet dass das
Beziehungen auf Augenhöhe sind z.B in
Schwellenländern auch deren
Energieversorgung mitdenken dass man die
nicht in Fossilien Energien treibt
sondern denen über diese auf über diese
Anlagen die gebaut werden müssen
erneuerbare Energien eben auch eine
Energieversorgung ermöglicht es müssen
entsaltungsanlagen für das Wasser gebaut
werden das kann die Wasserversorgung von
Ländern lösen und bei dem ganzen muss
man im Hinterkopf behalten dass wir im
Rahmen der geopolitischen Veränderungen
natürlich auch Allianzen brauchen wir
werden in Amerika und Europa 2030
ungefähr 12 Prozent der Bevölkerung
ausmachen und der Wald aus größte Teil
der Weltbevölkerung wird in anderen
Regionen leben wir können uns nicht
isolieren sondern wir müssen schauen
dass wir zu möglichst vielen der
unentschlossenen Ländern gute
Beziehungen aufbauen und mit denen
zusammen Wachstumschancen realisieren
insofern also dieser Fokus wie wachsen
wir in dieser Situation und was machen
wir hier in Deutschland und was bringt
das uns ähm der ist glaube ich einfach
der falsche weil wir müssen da sehr
global denken und überlegen wie
stabilisieren wir eigentlich die Rolle
Deutschlands und Europas in der Welt und
das ist ein völlig offenes Spiel wenn
man die entscheidenden
großen bevölkerungsreichen
Schwellenländer anguckt danke schön wir
haben genau
[Applaus]
guten Morgen Müller Michaelis
energiewirtschaftler aus Hamburg
ich beklage vor allem auch nach den
Ausführungen von Professor Grimm
einen intellektuellen GAP bei der
Betrachtung unserer zukünftigen sicheren
Energieversorgung eines Industrielandes
wie Deutschland wir steigen aus den
fossilen aus wir steigen aus der
Kernenergie aus wir steigen aus einer
energieversorgungsstruktur aus die über
Jahrzehnte entwickelt worden ist und
modellhaft für die ganze Welt gilt als
eine sehr sichere und auch
kostengünstige Energieversorgung wir
setzen voll jetzt auf die Erneuerbaren
die beim gegenwärtigen Stand der Dinge
19% unseres gesamten Energien nichts
ausmachen nachdem sie schon seit
anderthalb Jahre Jahrzehnten massiv
unterstützt worden sind 19%, am gesamten
GMX die Illusionen die daran besteht
dass sie eines Tages 100% ausmachen
würden ist so riesig groß dass ich nicht
begreife dass man
ja mit
gesunder normaler Mathematik auf diese
nicht auf diese Lücke stößt ich finde es
absurd und ich finde es auch unsinnig
dass wir
aus einem aussteigen aber auf der
anderen Seite
nur nur auf diese nur auf diese
Prognose gehen dass wir es eines Tages
schaffen aus 1900 zu machen könnten sie
Freundschaften irgendeine Frage stellen
müssen Frage ist schon meine Frage ist
wie beurteilt man den Umstand dass die
gesamte Welt alle Industrieländer Welt
auf Kerne gesessen dass der Welt klimaat
die Kernenergie als Teil der Lösung
unser klimapid und das der überwiegende
Mehrheit unserer
Nachbarn in Europa auf Kern der Gesetzen
und nur wir die sie eigentlich am besten
beherrschen aussteigen aber sie
gleichzeitig ja trotzdem nutzen weil sie
importieren von den Nachbarn
ja vielleicht zwei kurze Kommentare dazu
weil wir ja schon am Ende der Zeit sind
das eine ist dass wir in Deutschland
also ich halte das für sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass wir in der
Kernenergie wieder einsteigen weil wir
einfach von der Stimmung her in der
Bevölkerung das nicht werden aushandeln
können
wir sollten allerdings mit Ländern die
auf die Kernenergie setzen kooperieren
und keine Frontstellung aufbauen das was
in Europa gerade passiert dass man sich
da versucht gegenseitig die
transformationspfade vorzuschreiben das
ist nicht gut wir müssen gemeinsam voran
gehen und auch das komplementäre an den
beiden Lösungen sehen mit Blick auf die
Frage kann das denn funktionieren dass
wir unsere Energie Systeme umstellen da
würde ich jetzt mal auf die USA
verweisen ja mit dem Inflation reduction
Act ein massives Programm das den Ausbau
erneuerbare Energien und den Aufbau von
Kapazitäten zur Erzeugung von grünem
Wasserstoff und darauf basierenden
grünen Energieträgern massiv
beschleunigen wird die ähm die
Schätzungen für den Aufbau von
elektrolysekapazität für die USA und der
steigt das was man vor dem Inflation
reduction Act für die ganze Welt
erwartet hatte das ist massiv und das
bedeutet für uns vor allen Dingen dass
wir in unseren Möglichkeiten unseren
unsere Transformation voranzutreiben
beschränkt werden könnten dadurch dass
einfach diese Produktionskapazitäten für
die Anlagen gar nicht so schnell
aufgebaut werden können also wir müssen
eigentlich unsere Hausaufgaben machen
und beschleunigen und sehr schnell sein
damit wir uns nicht hinten anstellen
müssen um überhaupt Zugriff auf die
Produktionskapazitäten für Anlagen für
Infrastrukturen und so weiter zu
bekommen ich glaube dass die Dynamik die
wir da erleben werden wird viele von uns
überraschen und da sieht man eben auch
wie die gesellschaftliche Diskussion
damit umgeht solange die USA dann nicht
so aktiv waren china hat seine
Aktivitäten zwar in 5 Jahren
festgehalten aber nicht so groß
propagiert weltweit dachten wir wir nur
wir machen das kein anderer macht wir
werden jetzt eine Welt erleben wo uns
andere sehr sehr dynamisch überholen
werden und da werden wir uns noch
umgucken das heißt unsere
gesellschaftliche Diskussion sollte das
glaube ich auch mit wahrnehmen und wir
sollten da schon schauen dass wir
schneller vorankommen
das ist immer wieder erstaunlich wie
schnell 45 Minuten vergehen können wenn
man einen hochinteressantes Thema hat
und eine hochinteressante
Gesprächspartnerin vielen Dank Frau
Professor Grimm dass sie hier waren
vielen Dank für ihre Ausführung und
vielen dank ihnen fürs Zuhören für die
Fragen ja
[Applaus]